cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film le procès du siècle
réalisé par michael jackson avec rachel
weisz et tom wilkinson
je vous le dis de façon terre à terre il
est plus vrai qu'une femme est morte
dans la voiture et sénateur ted kennedy
a charm quick que dans une soi-disante
chambres à gaz à auschwitz
deborah lipstadt historienne et auteure
reconnue défend farouchement la mémoire
de l'autre elle se voit confronter un
universitaire extrémistes avocats de
thèse controversée sur le régime nazi
david hirai qui la met au défi de
prouver l'existence de la shoah dollars
acquis qu elle montre un document
prouvant que j'ai sensible du film est
traité sous forme de thriller juridique
et historique
l'espagne met en lumière la tentative de
manipulation et de revisionner nos deux
différences de l'holocauste à auschwitz
est aussi au coeur de la négation de
l'holocauste
au delà du scénario précis le philosophe
michael jackson revient sur un sujet
d'actualité
des haltes et respecte les flics news le
mensonge historique un croc
toi par conséquent il n'y a jamais eu de
chambres à gaz passe ou pas de leurs
costil voulez un slogan il a je ne suis
pas servi par d'excellents acteurs ce
film efficace bien écrit et interprété
se révèle essentielle et passionné
jamais produit
le procès du siècle est à découvrir
cette semaine à l'espace philippe nos
oreilles